CURIOUS CASE OF BIDEN’S BROKEN
FOOT, THAT MORE IN FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
BUT FIRST -- NEVER NORMAL AGAIN?
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THIS TIME OF YEAR IS USUALLY
FILLED WITH CHRISTMAS PARTIES,
BUSTLING RESTAURANTS, TRIPS TO
VISIT LOVED ONES, IT HAPPENS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY BUT OF COURSE
BECAUSE OF COVID FOR MOST OF US,
NOTHING SEEMS THE SAME.
MORE AMERICANS ARE ON EDGE, A SO
ARE LEGITIMATELY TERRIFIED OF
GETTING THE VIRUS, OTHERS WANT
TO END LOCKDOWNS AND ALL THESE
RULES THEY BELIEVE ARE ARBITRARY
AND DESTRUCTIVE.
EVEN CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
FRIENDS AND BETWEEN COLLEAGUES
CAN GET HEATED AS IT DID ON CNBC
THIS MORNING BETWEEN ANDREW ROSS
SORKIN AND RICK SANTELLI.
SANTELLI RIGHTLY NOTED THE
LOGICAL CHOICE BETWEEN KEEPING
BIG-BOX STORES OPEN BUT MOVED TO
SHUT DOWN RESTAURANTS.
>> THERE SHOULD BE AN ONGOING
DEBATE AS TO WHY A PARKING LOT
FOR A BIG BOX STORE IS
JAM-PACKED, NOT ONE PARKING SPOT
OPEN, WIRE THESE PEOPLE ANY
SAFER THAN A RESTAURANT WITH
PLEXIGLAS?
YOU CAN’T TELL ME THAT SHUTTING
DOWN WHICH IS THE EASIEST ANSWER
IS NECESSARILY THE ONLY ANSWER.
>> Laura: THEN MR. SORKIN
CLAIMED WITHOUT EVIDENCE THAT
RESTAURANTS SPREAD MORE COVID
THAN BIG STORES.
>> THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A BIG
BOX RETAILER AND A RESTAURANT OR
FRANKLY EVEN A CHURCH ARE SO
DIFFERENT IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> I DISAGREE, YOU CAN HAVE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND I CAN HAVE MINE.
>> IT’S SCIENCE, I’M SORRY.
>> IT’S NOT SCIENCE, 500 PEOPLE
IN A ROOM AREN’T ANY SAFER THAN
150 PEOPLE IN A RESTAURANT THAT
HOLD 600, I DON’T BELIEVE IT, I
LIVE IN AN AREA WHERE THERE’S A
LOT OF RESTAURANTS THAT HAVE
FOUGHT BACK AND THEY DON’T HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS.
>> Laura: HE IS RIGHT, PEOPLE
ARE BEGINNING TO FIGHT BACK --
YOU SAW A PROTEST OUTSIDE OF MAX
PUBLIC HOUSE WHICH IS A BAR IN
STATEN ISLAND WITH THE OWNER WAS
ARRESTED JUST FOR STAYING OPEN
JUST LIKE OTHER RESTAURANTS ARE
PERMITTED TO DO JUST A FEW
BLOCKS AWAY BUT THE ELITES THINK
THEY CAN JUSTIFY ANY HARM BEING
DONE TO WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS
BY INVOKING THE "SCIENCE."
INDIVIDUAL AMERICANS RIGHTS AND
LIVELIHOODS ARE EXPENDABLE IN
THIS BRAVE NEW SCIENTIFIC
WORLD -- PEOPLE NEED TO DO WHAT
THEY ARE TOLD NO QUESTIONS ASKED
ASKED.
>> YOU DON’T HAVE TO BELIEVE IT,
YOU’RE DOING A DISSERVICE TO THE
VIEWER.
>> YOU’RE DOING A DISSERVICE TO
THE VIEWER, YOU ARE.
>> I’M SORRY, I WOULD LIKE TO
KEEP OUR VIEWERS AS HEALTHY AS
POSSIBLE, THE IDEA OF PACKING
PEOPLE INTO RESTAURANTS --
>> I THINK OUR VIEWERS ARE SMART
ENOUGH TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
ON THEIR OWN, I DON’T THINK I’M
MUCH SMARTER THAN ALL THE
VIEWERS LIKE SOME PEOPLE DO.
>> Laura: THAT DEBATE REALLY
DOES CAPTURE WHAT’S GOING ON
ACROSS AMERICA, ALL OF US KNOWS
WHAT A TRAGEDY THIS VIRUS HAS
BEEN FOR SO MANY FAMILIES BUT
THE DISAGREEMENT SETTERS ON HOW
WE AS A FREE NATION MANAGE IT.
GAVIN NEWSOM, GRETCHEN WHITMER,
J.B. PRITZKER ARE ALL DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS WHOSE FIRST IMPULSE IS
TO SHUT STUFF DOWN AND STRIP YOU
OF YOUR FREEDOM WHILE MAKING
EXCEPTIONS ALL THE WHILE FOR
THEMSELVES.
WE ARE CALLING IT THE COVOCRACY,
THEY ALWAYS GET CAUGHT BREAKING
THEIR OWN RULES.
TODAY, THIS IS FASCINATING --
ALEX BERENSON HAS BEEN ON OUR
SHOW SO MANY TIMES HE PUBLISHED
AN EMAIL HE RECEIVED BY A MAN
WHO LIVES WITH HIS FAMILY IN
NORTHERN VIRGINIA -- HE AND HIS
WIFE HAVE GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT
ALLOW THEM TO WORK FROM HOME
WITH FEW INCONVENIENCES BUT NOT
SO FOR HIS WORKING-CLASS BROTHER
AND HIS FAMILY WHO STILL LIVE IN
THEIR HOMETOWN IN BROOKLYN.
WHEN NEW YORK CITY WENT INTO A
LOCKED DOWN, MY BROTHER WAS LAID
OFF AND HIS WIFE WAS FORCED TO
CLOSE HER HAIR SALON -- WHEN
NEW YORK CITY SCHOOLS CLOSE TO
MY BROTHER HAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HELP MY NEPHEW FINISHED
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH ZOOM, IF MY
BROTHER WANTED TO RELIEVE STRESS
THROUGH RECREATION, TOO BAD.
THE FACT IS THIS PANDEMIC HAS
ILLUSTRATED WHAT CONSERVATIVE
POPULISTS HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
YEARS THAT THE EDUCATED ELITES
ARE ALMOST COMPLETELY
DISCONNECTED FROM THE WAY
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS THINK
AND HOW THEY LIVE, NOT TO
MENTION HOW PROPAGANDISTIC MANY
IN THE MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT
HAVE BECOME,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" JUST
PUBLISHED RESPONSES TO AN
INFORMAL SURVEY OF
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS AND IT SEEMS
THAT EVEN WITH THE VACCINE, MOST
WOULD NEVER RECOMMEND THAT WE GO
BACK TO OUR OLD LIVES EVER
AGAIN -- THE ANSWERS RANGE FROM
MASKS FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS TO
WE’LL NEVER GO BACK TO OUR
PREPANDEMIC FREEDOMS.
REMEMBER, THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING AFTER WE WILL HAVE SPENT
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON VACCINES, LOST TRILLIONS IN
WEALTH, LOST YEARS OFF OUR
CHILDREN’S DEVELOPMENT AND
EDUCATION BUT STILL NOT GOING
BACK TO NORMAL?
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
HERE, HAS EVERYTHING BECOME TOO
POLITICAL?
THIS IS ALL ABOUT ACHIEVING THE
GLOBALISTS GOAL OF A GREAT RESET
OF OUR WORLD ECONOMY -- THE
PROPONENTS BY THE WAY YOU USE
BIDEN’S BUILD BACK BETTER MODEL
TO PUSH THEIR IDEA OF FORCED
WEALTH EQUALIZATION -- AMERICANS
WHO CARE ABOUT FREEDOMS AND
INDEPENDENCE BETTER START ASKING
QUESTIONS.
BY THE WAY, DON’T LET THE
EXPERTS WAVE YOU OFF BY SAYING
THIS IS WHAT THE SCIENCE SAYS
BECAUSE I BET MOST OF THEM
EITHER DON’T KNOW OR DON’T CARE